momento de conocer Cuáles son las
principales noticias en materia
económica y es por eso que nos acompaña
Juan Pablo lucumí Juan comenzamos en
Estados Unidos no una noticia que
implica la comunidad latina así es
Santiago buenas noches y todo gira con
respecto a los resultados de la agenda
económica de la administración de Joe
biden que ha llamado como biden
economics en una referencia a su
apellido y lo veremos a continuación en
los datos Y tiene que ver con que la
tasa de desempleo de la población de
latinos e hispanos se ubicó en el 4,3%
esto en junio siendo este su nivel más
bajo desde que se tienen registros en
cuanto a la tasa de pobreza infantil de
esta población también de los latinos en
un 7% este dato se tiene desde que él
llegó al poder y la tasa de desempleo de
la población afroamericana en un 6,4%
esto cumpliendo a una de las promesas de
la vicepresidenta kamala Harris y para
hacer una comparación en la misma tasa
para la población blanca está en el 3,3%
esto en datos de junio 2023 como para
que usted pueda ver la diferencia Por
último el 20% tiene que ver con una una
un escenario más rápido para la creación
de negocios de propiedad de latinos en
una década todos los datos que se
presentaron hoy en la casa blanca para
ver cómo avanza la economía en Estados
Unidos cuando Estados Unidos vamos a la
vecina Canadá para hablar de una
investigación a dos empresas Así es el
organismo de control de ética
corporativa de Canadá inició Este martes
investigaciones separadas contra Nike
Canadá y dynasty Gold después de que
llegaran quejas sobre las operaciones en
el extranjero de tres empresas
cranedienses presentadas por una
coalición de 28 organizaciones de la
sociedad civil en junio de 2022 un
informe del jefe de Derechos Humanos de
las Naciones Unidas dijo el año pasado
que el trato de China a los ulgures una
minoría étnica principalmente musulmana
que asciende alrededor de 10 millones en
chingan estamos hablando de China puede
tratarse de crímenes contra la humanidad
algo que Beijing ha negado
constantemente y que hielen la
secretaría del tesoro también lo negó
seguramente Juan que respondieron tanto
las empresas como las autoridades de
China pues dynasty Gold respondió por
correo electrónico diciendo que las
acusaciones son totalmente infundadas
mientras que Nike no respondió de
inmediato a los comentarios y la
embajada de china en Ottawa tampoco dio
respuesta a las peticiones de
periodistas de la agencia de routers
recordemos que estuvo en China también
hizo estas acusaciones Pues a China y
Beijing ha negado todo esto vamos a
hablar ahora de la inflación en el
gigante sudamericano hablamos de Brasil
se conoció el dato y hay varios puntos a
destacar en junio el dato intermensual
Tuvo una caída del 0,08% es decir un
dato negativo que no se registraba hace
mucho tiempo en Brasil por lo menos
desde 2017 no se tenía un dato similar
para ese mes y supone el primer dato
negativo en este año términos mensuales
con ese resultado de junio la inflación
anualizada Ahora sí vamos a ver la
comparación anual interanual en junio se
ubicó en 3,16% desde el 3,94% de mayo
según los datos del instituto brasileño
de geografía y estadísticas para el
sector de transportes influyó la caída
de los combustibles favorecidos por el
cambio de la política de precios de la
petrolera estatal petrobras que promovió
el gobierno del presidente Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva pero otro de los puntos a
destacar es que el mercado es de ese
país está expectante a que la tasa de
interés pueda caer desde el actual
13,75% que ha sido considerado demasiado
alto para el gobierno brasileño teniendo
en cuenta que la inflación va en
descenso como lo veíamos en el gráfico
El Banco Central ha argumentado que no
ha relajado su política monetaria debido
a la incertidumbre en el panorama
internacional y el escenario fiscal
nacional pero el presidente y su
administración dicen que esta decisión
no está y perjudica el crecimiento de la
economía de ese país Pese a que el dato
inflación ya llegó incluso a un nivel
menor del objetivo del banco veremos
cómo avanza la economía brasileña Juan
vamos ahora con Los indicadores del día
que nos dicen así Eso es paradójicamente
pese haber reportado una caída en su
dato de inflación el principal indicador
de Brasil cerró en rojo y aunque es su
segunda jornada de pérdida en realidad
fue una leve pérdida mientras que en
México y Argentina cerraron con pequeñas
ganancias Estados Unidos cerró en
positivo con los inversionistas
optimistas al dato de inflación que se
conocerá esta semana pues esperan que la
senda bajista siga con respecto al costo
de vida en ese país cifra del soy
Juan Pues hoy la cifra tiene que ver con
dos esqueletos de dinosaurios
reconstruidos uno es un reptil Volador y
el otro es una especie asociada con el
legendario monstruo del Lago nes Aunque
hay que aclarar que solo un esqueleto
asociado no se trata de la mítica
especie ambos se subastarán en Nueva
York que Estados Unidos y pues el
esqueleto Marino al monstruo se estima
que sea subastado entre 600 y 800 mil
dólares mientras que el reptil Volador
entre 4 y 6 millones de dólares la
pregunta que le hice a nuestra
presentadora María Clara es qué haría
una persona que compre estos esqueletos
de tan altas dimensiones no sé qué haría
una persona con esta compra a lo mejor
museos personas dedicadas a la
arqueología la verdad es que no sé Juan
yo por mi parte no creo que participe
así es Santiago Muchísimas gracias Juan
por otra Crónica completísima como
siempre nos vemos mañana con mucho más